tensión máxima en las calles de la
capital etíope en la región de tigre
miles de personas fueron arrestadas
arbitrariamente desde la semana pasada
incluyendo miembros del personal de las
naciones unidas- sexting nadie los 16
funcionarios nacionales fueron detenidos
mientras que 6 fueron liberados por
supuesto estamos trabajando activamente
con el gobierno de etiopía para asegurar
su liberación inmediata lewis las
detenciones se producen tras la
declaración la semana pasada de un
estado de emergencia previsto para seis
meses después de que las fuerzas leales
al frente de liberación popular de tigre
reivindicarán importantes avances en el
norte de etiopía lo que levantó alertas
de una posible invasión a la capital las
medidas de emergencia permiten al
gobierno detener sin orden judicial a
cualquier persona sospechosa de
colaborar con un grupo terrorista la
comisión de derechos humanos de etiopía
declaró que está supervisando un aumento
de los arrestos de tigray anos en addis
abeba el departamento de estado de eeuu
que washington encuentra los informes
preocupantes
entendemos por los informes que los
detenidos son tigray anos el acoso y la
detención por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad del gobierno etíope por
motivos étnicos son completamente
inaceptables es cumplirla exacto las
tensiones entre el gobierno etíope y la
onu se elevaron desde que estalló la
guerra en tira el pasado noviembre en
septiembre el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores expulsó a siete altos
funcionarios de la onu acusando los de
entrometerse en los asuntos del país
sólo unos días después de que la onu
advirtiera que el bloque humanitario de
la región ponía a cientos de miles de
personas en riesgo de hambruna